الى تطورات المواجهات المسلحه في السودان
الان اذ قال مراسله الجزيره الانفجارا هزه
صباح اليوم وسط العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
حيث رصد تصاعد الدخان في محيط القصر
الجمهوري كما افاد مراسلنا بسماع عدوي
انفجاريين في شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري
التي تشهد اشتباكات وقصفا متبادلا منذ عده
ايام وقد ردت قوه دعم السريه بمضادات
ارضيه على غارات الطيران الحربيه التابعه
للجيش في الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري ينضم
الينا الان من جنوب الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي الطاهر مرحبا بك معنا اذا
اطلعنا على الاجواء حيث انت صباح اليوم في
هذه الهدنه الجديده التي مازالت مستمره
نعم في جنوب الخرطوم ووسط الخرطوم نسمع
اصوات انفجارات قويه خاصه في وسط الخرطوم
يبدو ان هنالك اشتباك سواء كان بالمدفعيه
او الطيران لكن اصوات قويه في هذه اللحظات
يبدو ان الهدنه في هذه اللحظات هي هدنه
غير متماسكه وهشه ويبدو ان هنالك تطورات
عسكريه ميدانيه بحسب ما يقول الجيش
السوداني او الدعم السريع اذا كانت هنالك
اي تحركات ان الهدنه لا تلغي حق الرد
وكذلك هنالك تحليق للطائرات السودانيه
ربما خلال الساعات القادمه تكون معلومات
اكثر لان في مثل هذه الظروف تكون
المعلومات دائما شهيحه وتصدر دائما
المعلومات المؤكده من خلال بيانات يصدرها
الجيش السوداني او يزوره
الدعم السريع اما من حيث الوضع الانساني
وكذلك الاوضاع التي مثلا على الارض
بالنسبه للمواطنين هنالك تح حذر في مثل
هذه الظروف خاصه عندما يسمعون اصوات
الانفجارات او اي نوع من الاشتباكات لكنهم
يتحركون عفوا
يتحركون في الاسواق الشعبيه لمحاوله يعني
قضاء بعض الاحتياجات مثلا المواد الغذائيه
وغيرها ولكن ايضا نلاحظ ان هنالك تفاقم في
هذا الورد بسبب شحا السيوله وكذلك الحديث
عن ان هذه المواد الغذائيه يمكن ان تنفذ
باعتبار ان كل المخزون الموجود هو في داخل
الاحياء والمستودعات الكبيره اصابها التلف
واصابها كذلك النهب وكذلك توقفت المصانع
في كثير من المواقع هنالك محاولات من
ولايه الخرطوم وبعض الجهات تقول انها تسعى
لتكوين يعني لجان لانسياب هذه السلع الى
المواطنين خاصه ان الامور الان يعني الحرب
تدخل الاسبوع الثالث هذا يعني انه
في كل الظروف فان المواد ستكون شحيحه
وغاليه الاسعار يعني تبعا لذلك اصدرت اكثر
من ست ولايات قانون حاله الطوارئ او اعلنت
حاله الطوارئ محافظه على هذه المواد
الاستراتيجيه المواد السلعه الضروريه وعدم
نقلها من مكان الى اخر خاصه الان التجار
السوق السوداء بدوي ينشطون في بعض المواقع
خاصه المواقع المتاثره زي مثلا زي الخرطوم
مثلا وكذلك في بعض الويلات القريبه من
الخرطوم هنالك ايضا بعض الصيدليات فتحت
ابوابها ولكنها ايضا تخشى ان تتوقف
الامدادات بالنسبه اليها في الايام
القادمه هنالك شح كبير في الوقود حتى حركه
المواطنين بالسيارات اصبحت الان محدوده
جدا وحتى المغادرين المغادرين للخرطوم
الذين رغم ان اتراجع عاداتهم الى الى نسبه
قليله جدا جدا ولكنه ايضا يواجهون ازمه
الوق ارتفاع الاسعار يبدو ان الامور تسير
في هذا الاتجاه اذا لم تضع هذه الحرب او
زارها او تنجح الوساطات خاصه وان معظم
المواطنين الان يناشدون الاطراف هذا
الصراع الى وقف الحرب وتتصاعد ايضا
المناشدات للاوضاع الانسانيه وللبنيه
التحتيه ولغيرها من التحديات التي تواجه
السودان ولكن حتى على المستوى الوسطات وان
كانت الاقليميه او الدوليه يبدو انها تصل
الى طريق مسدود لانه كل النقاشات
والتصريحات يعني لا تراوح مكانها تروح
مكان فيه ما يختص مثلا بتعيين وممثلين او
الذهاب الى دوله محدده او المبدئيا
الاتفاق على وقف لاطلاق النار على الرغم
ان نحن نسمع معلومات ان هناك اتفاق يمكن
ان يكون بعد نهايه هذه الهدنه هدنه لمده
سبعه ايام ولكن هذه الهدنه تتخللها الكثير
من الخروقات وربما تنقصها ايضا مساله
عمليات التي يمكن ان تثبت هذه الهدنه من
حيث المراقبه ومن حيث الاشياء التي يمكن
ان تؤدي لحل شامل لهذه الازمه على كل
الامور تسير من ناحيه الانسانيه نحو تفاقم
بسبب الندره والظروف التي يعيشها الانسان
من حيث السيوله واغلاق الكثير من المصارف
ومن الناحيه الميدانيه والعسكريه ما تزال
هنالك يعني خروقات لهذه الهدنه واشتباكات
من حين الى اخر شكرا لك مراسل الجزيره من
جنوب الخرطوم الطاهر المرضي